[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen guten abend mit
mir im studio kristin otto für den sport
gelernt der krieg in der ukraine führt
zu immer mehr tragödien und prominenten
politischen hilfe rufen
[Musik]
wie helfen sie uns diesen krieg zu
stoppen mit eindringlichen worten redet
der ukrainische präsident den deutschen
abgeordneten ins gewissen und bittet um
mehr unterstützung
das sterben geht weiter wieder fallen
bomben in der ukraine
ob auch beim beschuss eines theaters in
mariupol menschen umkamen ist noch
unklar
wer hilft wie in deutschland die länder
drängen den bund er müsse die aufnahme
der flüchtlinge finanziell und
organisatorisch mit stämmen
die worte per video die aufwühlenden
appelle des ukrainischen präsidenten
heute morgen im bundestag sie begannen
verspätet offenbar weil es in der nähe
von selen ski einen angriff gab so wie
an vielen anderen orten der ukraine in
dem land zu sein bedeutet permanente
lebensgefahr darum suchten wohl auch
hunderte zivilisten in mariupol schutz
in einem theater auf das dann bomben
fielen julia schröter und volker duschek
ein satellitenbild des theaters von
mario pohl vor dem angriff es zeigt auf
der vorder und rückseite des gebäudes
ist der russisch das wort kinder auf den
boden geschrieben ein hinweis dass hier
zivilisten schutz vor bomben suchen
vergeblich das theater brennend und in
trümmern mehr als 1000 menschen sollen
sich darin aufgehalten haben ob es
todesopfer gab ist weiterhin unklar noch
in der nacht spricht der bürgermeister
von einem unfassbaren verbrechen
wir wollen die augen zumachen und den
alptraum vergessen der heute geschehen
ist das einzige wort was das geschehene
beschreibt ist völkermord an den
ukrainern die
ukraine macht russland verantwortlich
die truppen hätten eine große bombe auf
das theater abgeworfen moskau dementiert
dass umgehend und spricht von einer lüge
unter welchen umständen die menschen im
theater schutz gesucht haben zeigen
diese bilder die vor einigen tagen
gemacht wurden dicht an dicht gedrängt
sitzen die menschen darunter auch viele
kinder nur handy taschenlampen oder
kerzen spenden ein wenig licht
mariupol im südosten der ukraine die
stadt ist strategisch so wichtig denn
sie legt dort wo putin einen verbindungs
korridor zur annektierten krim schaffen
will die ukrainischen truppen versuchen
die stadt zu verteidigen
diese bilder zeigen wie auf einer straße
in mario pohl an russischer panzer von
einer drohne angegriffen wird seit mehr
als zwei wochen ist mario pohl
eingekesselt hilfsorganisationen nennen
die zustände katastrophal
immerhin gestern ist es mehreren tausend
menschen gelungen aus der stadt zu
fliehen trotz der gefahr beschossen zu
werden
die flucht war ein risiko aber bleiben
wäre noch gefährlicher gewesen darum
haben wir uns für die flucht entschieden
sie haben uns bombardiert wir haben kein
zuhause mehr auf den straßen liegen
leichen es ist die hölle wenn die hölle
existiert dann ist sie dort
doch mariupol ist nur ein schauplatz in
diesem krieg auch in anderen städten gab
es neue angriffe etwa in kharkiv und in
kiew in der hauptstadt wird ein 16
stöckiges wohnhaus getroffen wohl von
den trümmern einer im anflug
abgeschossenen rakete mindestens ein
mensch kam ums leben dieser mann hier
trauert um seine mutter drei menschen
wurden verletzt und viele weitere haben
ihr zuhause verloren es werden wohl
nicht die letzten sein
jetzt live zu katrin eigendorf ins
ukrainische oder kathrin international
großes entsetzen wie nimmt man die
bombardierung des theaters in mariupol
weiter westlich in odessa auf
ja das ist auch hier eigentlich das
hauptgesprächsthema bei den menschen und
was ich raus höre ist im moment
unglaublich viel schmerz ich habe viele
leute gesprochen die einfach geweint
haben verzweifelt sind darüber zu sehen
was dort passiert das im prinzip ganz
gezielt zivilisten und auch kinder
angegriffen werden ich denke mit der
rede heute vor dem deutschen parlament
hat sie lenski den ukrainern schon aus
dem herzen gesprochen mit vielem was er
da gesagt hat mit der hoffnung dass der
westen doch noch enger an die seite der
ukraine rückt doch mehr noch tut das ist
die große hoffnung der menschen auch
hier relativ klein sind die perspektiven
das wirklich bei den verhandlungen mit
russland so schnell etwas herauskommt
die meisten menschen mit denen ich hier
rede stellen sich doch darauf ein dass
dieser krieg durchaus noch lange dauern
kann was ich beobachte die
widerstandskraft und der wille hier zu
bleiben und für das land zu kämpfen der
ist ungebrochen trotz dieser
schrecklichen bilder aber die
perspektive dass das schnell hier zu
einem ende zu einem frieden führen
könnte doch sehr gering heute danke für
die einschätzung nach oder sagt katrin
eigendorf war das
deutliche worte von us-präsident beiden
der russlands vorgehen unmenschlich
nennt und putin einen kriegsverbrecher
ein vorwurf den moskau als unverzeihlich
zurückweist und verteile ich offenbar
auch wenn russische bürger den kreml
kurs nicht mittragen sie werden als
verräter gebrandmarkt und bedroht auch
unabhängige in und ausländische presse
darf und soll nicht mehr kritisch
berichten dürfen und das macht es noch
schwieriger
kriegssituationen einzuschätzen weil
beide seiten sich gegenseitig
beschuldigen anne gellinek
die umkämpfte stadt terni f 150
kilometer nördlich von kiew gestern
filmt ein ukrainischer kameramann diese
szene chaos rettungsversuche und mehrere
getötete zivilisten nach einem angriff
auf menschen die offenbar schlange
standen um brot zu kaufen die
ukrainische generalstaatsanwaltschaft
macht russland für die tat
verantwortlich moskau widerspricht
postwendend der sprecher des russischen
verteidigungsministeriums
die getöteten sind opfer des terrors
ukrainischer nationalisten bei den
bildern handelt es sich um eine erneute
inszenierung des ukrainischen
geheimdienstes sb die spielräume für in
und ausländische journalisten in
russland werden immer enger das wort
krieg ist verboten die letzte
unabhängige zeitung novaya gazeta
verpixelt es auf ihrer titelseite
um den staatlichen behörden keinen
vorwand zu liefern die journalistin
marina auf sie an die käufer die mit
einem anti kriegs plakat in die
hauptnachrichtensendung des
staatsfernsehens stürmte sagte im
bbc-interview
meine botschaft an die russischen
zuschauer ist ihr seid zombies der kreml
propaganda ich war ein kleines rädchen
in dieser propaganda maschine und ja ich
fühle mich dafür verantwortlich der
kreml hat verstanden dass er dabei ist
den informationskrieg gegen die ukraine
zu verlieren und dreht den spieß um die
sprecherin des außenministeriums wirft
westlichen medien lügen und verzerrungen
vor die westlichen massenmedien werden
die verantwortung dafür nicht von sich
weisen können zeitungs magazin und
fernsehjournalisten haben das alles mit
eigenen händen fabriziert keine viele
journalisten sollen russland bereits
verlassen haben unabhängige
berichterstattung wird täglich
schwieriger
christian sam ist für uns in moskau
christian gerade gesehen die presse
stark unter druck aber das gilt auch für
die russische zivilbevölkerung nehmen
sie das war
ja also die repression gegen die medien
und auch gegen die opposition die
erleben wir jetzt schon seit mehreren
jahren hier müssen wir das beobachten
aber so schlimm wie heute war es noch
nie und dann muss man davon ausgehen
dass schon die nächste repressionswelle
droht gegen anders denken hier putin
sagt allen gegnern die seinen kurs nicht
unterstützen denen sagt er den kampf an
also all diejenigen die gegen diese
spezielle militäroperationen sind das
ist das wort für den krieg so wie er
hier bezeichnet wird das wort krieg ist
hier verboten haben gerade im beitrag
auch gehört putin sagt auch das
russische volk sei standhaft genug zu
unterscheiden zwischen wahren patrioten
auf der einen seite und abschaum und
verrätern auf der einen seite ja und
seine gegner können diese worte nur als
das verstehen was es ist nämlich eine
neue kampfansage
christian sam vielen dank nochmals kaum
standing ovations für den ukrainischen
präsidenten der heute per video im
bundestag zugeschaltet war die lenski
hatte zuvor schon in anderen westlichen
parlamenten geredet aber heute heute war
es anders nicht nur weil seine worte
deutschlands rolle auch kritisch
beleuchteten sondern weil die opposition
darüber gerne noch diskutiert hätte
stattdessen ging man zur tagesordnung
über weniger fasst das zusammen
der präsident zugeschaltet aus dem krieg
in kiew wird den applaus abwarten dann
diesem parlament ins gewissen reden wir
hier selten gehört die deutschen seien
verantwortlich für eine neue mauer in
europa eine mauer zwischen freiheit und
unfreiheit
täglich jedes jahr wiederholen die
politiker wieder und jetzt sehen wir
dass diese worte nichts wert sind in
europa wird ein volk vernichtet es wird
versucht alles zu vernichten was uns
lieb ist wofür wir leben
ein appell an das historische gewissen
deutschlands sie lenski fordert keine
militärische hilfe aber härtere
sanktionen gegen russland stoppt der
energieimporte beitritt zur europäischen
union
lieber bundeskanzler chance geben sie
deutschland die führungsrolle die
deutschland verdient unterstützen sie
den frieden unterstützen sie die ukraine
helfen sie den krieg zu stoppen es lebe
die ukraine
wieder applaus kaum aber hat sich so
gänzlich verabschiedet geht der
bundestag ohne pause zur tagesordnung
über geburtstagsglückwünsche regularien
als nächstes impfpflicht das wollen
nicht alle so hinnehmen das beginnt eine
paradoxe debatte ob man eine debatte
führen soll
und herren wann denn wenn nicht jetzt
eine diskussion eine zwischenbilanz eine
frage an uns selbst sie müssen wir
aufpassen dass sie nicht nach 100 tagen
schon so arrogant sind wie andere nach
16 jahren der euro-dollar-kurs oder doch
die ampelkoalition bleibt dabei
tagesordnung seit tagesordnung olaf
scholz antwortet auf den ukrainischen
präsidenten später aus dem kanzleramt
deutschland leistet hier seinen beitrag
und wird das weiter tun
eines aber gehört auch klar und deutlich
ausgesprochen die nato wird nicht
militärischen diesen krieg eingreifen
solidarität wollte das parlament
beweisen gezeigt hat es einen für alle
beschämenden auftritt
und die komplette rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten finden sie auch auf zdf.de
heute beziehungsweise in der heute app
seit beginn des ukraine krieges sind
mehr als drei millionen menschen aus
ihrer heimat in andere länder geflüchtet
ziel von hunderttausenden ukrainern ist
auch die republik moldau bekannt auch
als moldawien unsere reporterin barbara
lueg berichtet aus der stadt paar lanka
direkt an der grenze zur ukraine
wer darf mit wer fährt wohin wer muss
noch war
was ich an der grenze im moldawischen
paar lanker derzeit abspielt
sind dramen tragödien spontane
entscheidungen die vielleicht über leben
und tod entscheiden in nessa will nicht
bleiben sie geht zurück in die ukraine
heimweh sie rennt aber gemein man wartet
auf der anderen seite der grenze
andré bemüht sich derweil um ordnung
versucht die menschen im chaos zu
erheitern
sind ein tolles publikum wenn ich singen
könnte würde ich für sie singen mit
dem bus zur verpflegungsstation hinter
ihnen allen liegt heimat vertrautes ein
leben menschen die blieben was vor ihnen
liegt weiß niemand über 300.000
flüchtlinge sind inzwischen über die
grenze ins bettelarme nachbarland
moldawien geflohen über 100.000 tiere
blieben anna und ihre tochter katharina
atmen gerade mal durch
wir kommen aus odessa und haben bomben
und raketen gehört wir haben sie gehört
und hatten so angst dass es so wird wie
in frage
ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich mit 70
aufstehen und gehen muss
für die beiden geht es nun mit dem bus
nach deutschland und währenddessen
strömen weitere menschen aus der ukraine
über die grenze
ja wenn millionen krieg erleben müssen
millionen auf der flucht sind brauchen
sie hilfe und so wäre es möglich über
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch auf spenden zdf.de und auf
der cdf textseite 890 zum
kriegsgeschehen und den konsequenzen
sowie reaktionen heute auch wieder ein
zdf spezial gleich im anschluss an
unsere sendung ja wie kann man den
geflüchteten aus der ukraine helfen eine
sehr wichtige frage auch für die bund
länder runde die heute nachmittag
zusammen kam von der registrierung
entschuldigung registrierung bis zur
eingliederung ins tägliche leben wurde
sehr viel besprochen aber die länder
chefs und chefinnen die haben deutlich
gemacht an den kosten dafür soll sich
bitte der bund beteiligen patricia
wieder mit mehr
nach wie vor herrscht ausnahmezustand am
berliner hauptbahnhof nach wie vor
kommen hier täglich über 1000
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine an das land
berlin fordert seit tagen mehr
unterstützung des bundes und eine
gerechtere verteilung auf die länder die
der bundeskanzler im anschluss an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch
zusagte die bewältigung dieser
herausforderung ist eine gemeinsame
aufgabe unseres staates für die wir uns
auch gemeinsam verantwortlich fühlen und
diese gemeinsame verantwortung erstreckt
sich ausdrücklich auch auf die frage der
finanzen bis zum siebten april sollen
nun konkrete vereinbarungen zur
finanzierung erarbeitet werden denn
alleine könnten die kommunen ist nicht
schaffen die flüchtlinge zu versorgen so
der nordrhein westfälische
ministerpräsident
der brutalität dieses angriffskriegs
solidarität und nächstenliebe
entgegen die ecke für die flüchtlinge
ist eine enorm große aufgabe ja es ist
eine nationale aufgabe
sie kann von bund ländern und kommunen
gemeinsam gestemmt werden
diesmal müsse aber auch von anfang an
die integration in den mittelpunkt
gestellt werden
und das bedeutet dass wir eben von
anfang an auch diese entwicklung die wir
jetzt sehen nicht nur als belastung
betrachten sondern auch als chance denn
es gibt in deutschland ein großes
wachstumshemmnis und das ist der
fachkräftemangel
es kommen menschen die qualifiziert sind
eine perspektive zu haben das war auch
thema beim besuch des bundespräsidenten
am berliner hauptbahnhof heute bei
seinen gesprächen mit flüchtlingen
diesmal so steinmeiers eindruck wüssten
die deutschen dass sie sich dauerhafter
verantwortlich fühlen müssten als bei
den syrischen flüchtlingen
und bei den bund länder beratungen da
ging es auch um den corona kurs sie
wissen ab sonntag laufen die meisten
corona maßnahmen aus zu früh sagen viele
länder sie nutzen eine übergangsfrist
und kritisieren die schutzregeln seien
viel zu ungenau heike slansky
heftige kritik am abgespeckten
infektionsschutzgesetz unverständnis bei
den ländern warum künftig nur noch ein
geringerer basisschutz gelten soll bei
bedarf eine hotspot regelung obwohl es
so viele infektionen wie noch nie gibt
das halte ich für eine sackgasse in die
wir uns da hinein bewegen weil der bund
einerseits sagt wir sollen die dinge
jetzt vor ort selber regeln aber er gibt
uns nicht die instrumente dass wir es
vor ort regeln können und er zwingt uns
dass wir noch einmal 16 parlamente
beteiligen müssen auf druck der fdp
sollen ab ende der woche fast alle
maßnahmen fallen die meisten länder
haben sich mit der übergangsfrist noch
zwei wochen zeit gekauft so lange können
die alten corinna regeln fortbestehen
kritik am verfahren und inhalt der bund
jetzt die verantwortung dafür dass den
ländern die werkzeuge für einen
schnellen und effektiven basis schutz
genommen werden und länder waren in der
pandemie immer erfolgreich denn sie
gemeinsam gehandelt haben die länder
sind auch in zukunft bereit dazu scholz
bleibt dabei appelliert an die
eigenverantwortung
der pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei
deshalb ist jede und jeder gut beraten
die gewohnten vorkehrungen zu halten
also hygieneregeln zu beherzigen nach
möglichkeit abstand zu halten und ob
freiwillig zum eigenen schutz
was sie zu tragen
das infektionsschutzgesetz die kritik
daran zu schwammig zu wenig instrumente
zu kompliziert morgen soll es erst im
bundestag anschließend im bundesrat
verabschiedet werden
contra banerjee in berlin zu den corona
beschlüssen da soll es großen unmut in
der bund länder runde gegeben haben was
wissen sie darüber ja das muss ein sehr
unangenehmer teilt dieser veranstaltung
gewesen sein für olaf scholz auch wenn
er selber das in der pressekonferenz im
nachhinein eine sehr konstruktive
diskussion genannt hat das passt nicht
ganz zu dem was wir an zitaten aus der
verhandlungsrunde von aus
teilnehmerkreisen noch während der
gespräche zugespielt bekommen haben da
sieht man das parteiübergreifend es
heftige kritik gegeben hat an den
geplanten änderungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz die länder fühlen
sich nicht mitgenommen sie haben den
eindruck da passiert das gegenteil von
dem was sie sich gewünscht haben
stellvertretend für die bundesländer
sagte hendrik wüst der vorsitzende der
mpk die notfallmaßnahmen seien zu
langsam die hürden seien zu hoch und das
ganze sei rechtlich nicht umsetzbar so
da hat es richtig gekracht allein die
länder können daran jetzt nichts ändern
sie werden über diese änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes nicht
mitbestimmen das macht der bundestag und
die meisten bundesländer behelfen sich
jetzt eben erst einmal damit dass sie
die übergangsfrist nutzen und bis anfang
april maßnahmen verlängern streit über
corona kommt einem bekannt vor bleibt
wahrscheinlich so vielen dank und ella
nach berlin im bundestag heute auch dies
erstmals eine debatte über
gesetzentwürfe für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht kontrovers geführt durch die
fraktionen hinweg gesundheitsminister
lauterbach warnte vor neuen
freiheitsbeschränkungen im herbst wenn
es keine impfpflicht gebe aus der union
kommt der vorschlag ein in free gäste
einzurichten und aus der fdp der
vorstoss vorerst nur eine beratung
vorzuschreiben
jetzt zu einem wegweisenden urteil für
gastronomen und betriebsinhaber die im
corona locker und schließen mussten sie
haben keinen anspruch auf individuelle
staatliche entschädigung für ihre
einnahmeausfälle
so hat der bundesgerichtshof entschieden
der gesetzgeber habe mit den
verschiedenen hilfsprogrammen seine
pflicht erfüllt
paukenschlag im saarland schon lange war
oskar lafontaine mit seiner partei der
linken heftig zerstritten jetzt zehn
tage vor der landtagswahl verlässt er
sie überraschend und kommt damit einem
möglichen ausschluss zuvor lafontaine
war von 2007 bis 2010 vorsitzender der
linkspartei zuvor war er von 1995 bis 99
chef der spd und unter bundeskanzler
schröder finanzminister
der krieg in der ukraine hat
auswirkungen auf die internationale
zusammenarbeit auch im weltall denn auf
der internationalen raumstation arbeiten
amerikaner und russen eng zusammen aber
die zunehmenden spannungen zwischen den
beiden großmächten belastend das
gemeinsame projekt zurzeit ist auch der
deutsche astronaut matthias maurer an
bord mehr erfahren wir von susanne
freitag
nach dem kalten krieg wurde die
raumstation iss zum vorzeigeprojekt
internationaler kooperation noch im
november empfingen russische kosmonauten
matthias maurer und seine kollegen zwei
russen zwei amerikaner ein deutscher das
aktuelle forscherteam doch auf der erde
ist krieg russlands raumfahrt chef
dimitri rogosin drohte damit die iss
abstürzen zu lassen später postete er
ein video russische kosmonauten fliegen
zur erde und lassen den amerikanischen
kollegen oben dann stürzte iss ab ein
scherz sei das hieß es später reine
provokation
die europäische raumfahrtorganisation
esa reagierte heute
vielleicht etwas überspitzt und etwas
verschärfter dargestellt aber natürlich
wir nehmen das sehr ernst und der
westliche teil wenn ich ihn so nennen
kann verlässlich auf russland um die
station wieder zu anzuheben und in den
richtigen ort verbringen weil die
stationen im lauf der monate leicht ab
sinkt dieser mars-rover sollte im
september starten jetzt wurde die
mission exomars abgesagt russland sorgte
für trägerraketen und landeplattform
wir haben keine wahl die sanktionen die
unsere mitgliedsländer auf russland
ausüben die machen einen start unmöglich
faktisch unmöglich operationell
unmöglich und moralisch auch zum ersten
mal ist durch einen krieg auf der erde
auch die zukunft der kooperation im all
ernsthaft gefährdet
dann machen wir jetzt hier mit sport
weiter und fußball bundesliga dortmund
macht es wieder spannend ist in den
titelkampf genau und das freut viele ja
acht spieltage vor schluss ist der
rückstand des bvb auf spitzenreiter
bayern münchen auf vier punkte
geschrumpft dank des 1 0 der dortmunder
im nachholspiel in mainz der erfolg
keine glanzleistung aber es reicht sie
schrien es heraus dieser sieg war
wichtig dortmund kämpft sich heran an
tabellenführer bayern ja ein erwartet
schweres spiel hier meint es war klar
was auf uns zukommt und am ende glaube
ich dass wir natürlich mit diesem
standard tor kurz vor schluss der
glückliche gewinner heute sind das spiel
ohne die schlüsselspieler reus und
hummels bot insgesamt viel hektik aber
wenig torchancen
rowling harland noch nicht topfit ab der
57 minute aber dabei seinen ersten
torschuss parierte robin zentner danach
kam nicht mehr viel bis zur 87 minute
und axel witsel mit dem 1 0 siegtreffer
für die titeljagd müssen auch am sonntag
gegen köln
erleichterung bei thomas tuchel der
trotz der wirtschaftlichen sorgen des
vereins mit dem fc chelsea im
viertelfinale der champions league steht
den entscheidenden treffer zum 2 1 sieg
beim französischen vertreter osc lille
erzielte cesar azpilicueta in der 71
minute mit dem knie nun droht dem
titelverteidiger in der runde der
letzten acht zu hause eine lehre kulisse
da der ticketverkauf wegen der
sanktionen gestoppt ist und die
viertelfinal-auslosung zeigen wir morgen
ab 12 uhr im livestream bei zdf heute
und in der zdf mediathek
corona bremst sebastian vettel aus er
befindet sich in isolation nico
hülkenberg vertritt ihn am wochenende
beim start der formel 1 saison in
bahrain und auch herthas neuer trainer
felix magath wurde corona positiv
getestet damit fällt sein bundesliga
comeback nach fast neun eineinhalb
jahren am samstag gegen hoffenheim
vorerst aus der 68 jährige soll die alte
dame vor dem abstieg retten tja meine
schwierige mission
so weltweites wissen sie reagieren
menschen mit großer anteilnahme und
solidarität auf den krieg in der ukraine
auch in madrid mit taxis erreichten
gestern abend mehr als 130 ukrainische
flüchtlinge die spanische hauptstadt
erschöpft aber glücklich
zuvor waren 60 taxifahrer auf eigene
kosten mehr als 3000 kilometer richtung
ukrainische grenze gefahren um die
flüchtlinge zu holen das ist ein zeichen
großer gastfreundschaft und
menschlichkeit in zeiten des krieges
zum wetter das wieder sonniger wird
gibt's gleich mehr von katja horneffer
das heute-journal ab 21 uhr 45 unter
anderem interviewt marietta slomka den
nato-generalsekretär zum ukraine trick
gibt es dann nach und zugleich das zdf
spezial wir sagen dankeschön abend und
wenn sie mögen bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend noch trennt die kleine
kaltfront von tief gesine das hoch
oliver von dem hoch peter was wird sich
aber am wochenende ändern gut zu
erkennen auf diesen satelliten film ist
auch diese scharfe grenze der wolken sie
sehen im nordwesten war es heute
nachmittag schon klar dichtere wolken
halten sich allerdings auch in der nacht
noch zwischen der uckermark und dem
alpenrand und im südwesten kann es auch
ein bisschen regnet im nordwesten
dagegen wird es klar da bilde sich zum
teilen leben das kann auch glatz seien
auf den straßen denn dort sinken die
temperaturen auf null bis minus 4 grad
im osten und im süden bleibt es bei 8
bis 4 grad milder wenig temperatur am
morgen liegen in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen sowie acht grad am
mildesten wird es im rhein main gebiet
mit 16 grad im westen aber auch in
schleswig-holstein scheint die sonne
morgen schon wieder zum teil strahlend
vom blauen himmel im osten dagegen gibt
es noch dichtere wolkenfelder auch
ausgelöst vom saharastaub in den
nächsten tagen ist das mit dem
saharastaub dann vorbei uns erwartet
etwas schnee oder schneeregen im
erzgebirge am samstag danach aber
dominiert sonnenschein es wird von tag
zu tag milder guten abend